info intox avec anthony st léger bons
joueurs ont tout bon jour l'ukraine a
toujours elle a remporté 1 c'était ce
week end le concours de l'eurovision
l'interprète du coup du groupe un
vainqueur est accusé d'avoir fait un
salut nazi après sa victoire
effectivement une victoire remportée
haut la main par ole psiu caisson groupe
kadouch orchestra voilà ce qu'il a fait
à la après sa prestation après la
prestation du groupe en quittant la
scène on va la revoir parce que c'est
assez fugace regarder je vais m'arrêter
dessus voilà c'est ce bras levés qui a
interpellé sept internautes par exemple
qui s'interroge quelqu'un va-t-il
quelque chose de différent là on voit
que la vidéo est un peu plus longue et
on voit aussi que le haut de l'image est
rogné ne voyant pas donc la main en
question et ce sont ces vidéos et cette
capture d'écran qui ont beaucoup
interpellé des images volontairement
trompeuse qui sont utilisées donc pour
affirmer qu'il s'agit d'un salut nazi
c'est faux et la vérification a de ce
fait rapidement lorsque vous vous rendez
tout simplement sur le site de france
télévisions pour revoir le direct en
france télévisions qui diffusait ce
concours regardez l'image elle est là
c'est sur la gauche vous avez ici donc
le chanteur qui va lever la main mais
tout simplement la main ouverte pour
saluer son public
rien à voir donc avec le salut nazi et
cette même scène elle nous est offerte
aussi parce sous un autre angle 1 parce
cette twittos qui insiste bien
d'ailleurs sur cette tromperie arrêter
d'inventer des choses qui ne le sont pas
ici on voit bien qu'il a la main ouverte
et qui nous saluait alors on le sait
cette référence au nazisme n est
évidemment pas anodine dans le contexte
de la guerre en ukraine puisque vladimir
poutine le président russe s'en sert et
justifie son intervention militaire par
sa volonté justement 2d nazifié
d'ukraine faisant des liens entre
l'idéologie l'idéologue l'idéologie
nazie pardon et le pouvoir ukrainien
mais toujours sur le même thème des
utilisateurs de réseaux sociaux assure
que les pousses de l'un des combattants
du régime en azote celui qui défend la
ville de mario paul est une néo nazis
qui plus est invité par la télévision
française effectivement à katerina
prokopenko l'épousé d'un des soldats qui
se bat actuellement à azov talent dans
l'usiné à marioupol a été interviewé
alors par nos soins on le voit sur notre
site rendre compte du quotidien de son
époux elle a témoigné aussi chez nos
confrères de lci et de bfm tv c'est
précisément lors de ses deux dernières
interventions que plusieurs internautes
ont prétendu qu'elle avait des
sympathies néo nazis pour preuve ces
photos des internautes qui ont fait
ressurgir ces photos reprises ici et là
alors on voit de gauche à droite une
jeune femme assise ressemblante faire un
salut nazi tenir une âme ensuite avec un
drapeau des jeunesses hitlériennes et
puis enfin bourg et un t-shirt avec un
symbole évidemment très reconnaissable
régler la croix gammée celui ce symbole
du troisième reich et bien la recherche
d'image l'inversé havas nous donner
l'identité cette jeune femme ce n'est
pas caterina prokopenko non c'est cette
femme s'appelle vittaz avérous qu'à elle
et lui craignait elle a 25 ans et elle
est ouvertement néo nazis on retrouve
plusieurs articles de presse d'ailleurs
évoquant cette interview de la jeune
femme fait en 2014 par le magazine elle
qui la présentait comme une simple
volontaires ukrainienne simple
combattante volontaires interview qui
par conséquent a suscité pas mal de
polémiques et qui a conduit le magazine
a présenté ses excuses assurant qu'il
ignorait tout de ces agissements
d'autres vins internautes ont partagé
cette fois l'image de trois jeunes
filles blondes qui font le salut nazi en
assurant que l'une d'elles un serait
caterina prokopenko les pousse donc un
de ce combattant du régiment azoff oui
tout à fait cette publication twitter du
13 mai par exemple regardons de plus
près donc la ressemblance se ferait
entre caterina prokopenko à gauche et
donc cette fille envers à droite alors
grâce à la recherche d' image inversée
au site italien de vérification open on
sait que cette image est en fait un même
qui circulent depuis au-moins février
2010 et en aucun cas l'image a été lié à
katerina prokopenko l'une des
occurrences elle nous ramène sur ce site
des motivations point m e ou le 21
novembre 2010 l'un des internautes écrit
c'est la pologne avant tout on garde ça
dans le conduit de la tête on trouve
aussi en 2010 est cette fois d'un site
d'archivés
de discussions du forum for jeunes et on
retrouve cette photo avec cette les gens
polis games white pride autre référence
à la pologne également la même photo
publiée cette fois sur un site coréen en
2015 on envoie c'est ces femmes prises
de pied et le filigrane de l'utilisateur
ici que l'on voit point apl pour pologne
donc publié sur un compte polonais qui
depuis a été supprimé et puis on note
aussi ce qu'on pouvait légèrement
apercevoir dans l'image d'origine c'est
ce t-shirt ici iluv football mais le
coeur on le voit est aux couleurs de la
pologne rouge et blanc alors les
recherches n'ont pas permis de donner
une date précise quant à cette photo ni
de données avec certitude la nationalité
des femmes en question mais vous l'aurez
compris rien à voir avec katerina
prokopenko qui a d'ailleurs démenti les
affirmations selon lesquelles elle avait
fait un salut nazi sur son compte
twitter on sait utiliser ces photos
manipulatoire pour lier l'ukraine à
l'idéologie l'idéologie nazie décidément
est un leit motiv et là c'est vrai que
la présence d'anciens néo nazis parmi
des combattants du régiment à d'azov n'y
est pas on le sait je le disais que
vladimir poutine appuyé cette rhétorique
là dessus je vous renvoie d'ailleurs à
plusieurs un fox traités par le site les
équipes des observateurs de france un
quart et ne croyez pas tout ce qu'on
vous montre un lancer c'est surtout sur
la guerre en ukraine d'ailleurs sa story
on retient chaque soir de ses a plongé
dans ces fausses infos avec vous anthony
st léger info ou intox c'était sur
france 24 reste avec nous on se retrouve
dans moins de quatre minutes pour un
nouveau journal
[Musique]